hot breath he says you're described as a
comics comic
how do you feel about that and what is
your interpretation of that
phrase also do you have a favorite
comedian that you
describe as a comics comic
thanks for the question chase um yeah i
take that as
as a compliment you know amongst
comedians
that is uh high praise you know when
you're known as a comics comic
because i think what it means is uh that
you make comedians laugh
too uh because comedians we can get a
little bit jaded
uh you know we can kind of we see so
much comedy
uh that at times you know maybe we're a
little bit harder
to get to laugh um so yeah to me i think
it just
maybe says that my peers respect me and
that
that has always meant a lot to me so
that's that's a good thing
and uh when i think of a comics comic
the imme the immediate person that comes
to mind is david tell
uh he's the guy like coming up through
new york city
that all of the comedians would stand in
the back of the room
and watch you know uh because as i said
we see so many
so many comedians we see so much comedy
we respect everybody
but when when you have comedians lining
up in the back of the room and stopping
to watch you
that's high praise so david tell is
really the pinnacle
of a comic's comic in my mind
it's a fine line in terms of your comics
comic
you get the respect of your peers that's
awesome but your peers aren't going to
pay the bills
you know and it's kind of a tough it's a
tough balancing act there
i mean what is your opinion on that
well that's a good point i think that's
part of it too
uh because at times when they say a
comics comic they mean
that the audience doesn't get them like
maybe somebody like larry david
back in the day before he started
writing with seinfeld
uh i heard you know i never saw him he
was a little bit before my time as a
stand-up
uh but i heard he was pretty adversarial
and would kind of like go with the crowd
and do these crazy things
and kind of maybe walk off stage you
know uh
but the the comics were always cracking
up um
so that's a different type of comics
comic uh
i don't really see myself in that
category like i i try to make the crowd
laugh
and uh i don't really have an
antagonistic relationship with the
audience
um so i you know my approach is of
course always to make
the audience laugh and for people to
have a good time
uh but yeah the fact that comedians also
respect me uh is is important to me
um but yeah i know what you're saying
like some at times there are people
that the business doesn't know what to
do with because they're
too bizarre or you know comedians love
them
but maybe the crowd doesn't get them or
they're too avant-garde uh
yeah but i've you know fortunately for
me i've been able to make a living and
it hasn't really
affected you know like like i said my i
see my first job
is to make people laugh you know boom
great yeah great point there